moi depuis que j'ai un iphone enfin un
smartphone je suis pas spécialement
accroc j'arrive vraiment à l'utiliser
avec modération
on se rend compte que le smartphone
c'est vraiment une drogue quand on passe
une soirée avec ses potes comme ça et ça
me dérange pas on fait une photo pour
l'instant g c'est vrai qu'avec les
smartphones on dirait que les gens et
qui fut la vraie vie quand tu fais un
concert il ya tout le monde qui filme et
personne ne regarde le truc en live en
plus c'est très bien que cette vidéo tu
vas jamais à regarder et mon gars hier
j'étais un concert c'était tellement
énorme
m ah ouais et c'était quel groupe à ça
je sais par avance je filmais donc mais
j'avoue moi même je suis tellement
habituée et sur mon smartphone tout le
temps il ya des moments où quand
j'utilise je me rend même plus compte 13
euros + 4 euros ce qui nous fait un
total de 1 ou 2 combien déjà
attendez je le fais de tête de tête ça
fait 13 + 4 17
voilà exactement je crois que les
personnes âgées sont pas très au courant
de tout ce qu'on peut faire avec un
smartphone la fois j'ai demandé à une
vieille dame de me prendre en photo avec
un pote je vous jure elle a fait comme
ça allez les gars on se ressert ont fait
un sourire à les cheese
je pense qu'elle est pas mal hein
on verra au développement mais je pense
j'ai mon petit talent de photographe
franchement il existe un milliard
d'applications pour les smartphones mais
elles sont toutes plus inutiles les unes
que les autres
attend l'application boussole est
vraiment un mec qui utilise sa web un
navet excuse-moi question question bête
mais ce soir on a bien on avait rendez
vous au nord-ouest
d'accord j'ai cru j'étais sud est
n'importe quoi
tout alors nord ouest nord ouest
je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
l'impression que les mecs qui ont des
iphone ils s'en foutent complètement de
toutes les autres marques de smartphones
par contre les mecs qui ont des
smartphones on sait pas pourquoi mais il
déteste tous les iphone bah moi si tu
veux mon exclusif et 600 millions de
pixels par photo je sais pas si tu sais
pas si tu réalises mais bon quand
j'entends dire l'iphone souci l'iphone
cela ça me fait ça me fait doucement
sourire entre collègues ou on auricane
non en ricane c'est c'est ridicule l es
tu doives iphone 5 est gratuit wes te
plaît pas mais à linverse ceux qui ont
pas du tout de smartphones qui ont pas
les moyens d'en avoir
à chaque fois ils me font vraiment
culpabiliser en avoir le dernier tweet
de françois hollande est énorme
regarde banon je peux pas moi j'ai pas
de smartphone mois moi j'ai que ça
toute cette merde
à
battu cette façon ça c'est des conneries
1 le plus important c'est que tu puisse
téléphoner avec n'ont même pas le mien
et john keller mais je suis tellement
habituée à biper mon téléphone dès que
je le perds quelque part que maintenant
d'experts un truc j'ai envie de le bip
et j'ai envie de bébé mais clé j'ai
envie de bp la télécommande et même
parfois j'ai envie de biper cergy cergy
soul et smartphones
c'est censé simplifier la vie mais en
fait ça va compliquer avec la correction
orthographe par exemple quand tu écris
des mots ton portable il décide tout
seul d'envoyer d'autres mots à ta place
est salut juliette
c'était sympa ce petit ciné j'espère à
bientôt je vais tuer toute ta famille
avec la lance grenades car je suis néo
nazis mais tout le monde est un peu
accros au smart phone c'est comme ça
c'est normal c'est juste parce que c'est
nouveau que ça choque les gens au jeu
sort qu'à l'époque où ils ont inventé le
livre bassa du chantier tout le monde au
début
jason des cartons geek c'est pas parvenu
que trois pages aujourd'hui tu as luc
trois pages
mais moi je crois que qu'on a je lisais
des pages tout à coup pour rien moi ton
âge je mangeais des cailloux
c'est un facteur dans [ __ ] merci d'avoir
regardé ma vidéo n'hésitez pas à lâcher
un petit commentaire si vous voulez vous
exprimer ou simplement à vous abonner à
la chaîne youtube c'est gratuit voilà
allez bientôt tu quand même sortir des
six vous plaît
je ne suis plus gentil le 10 heures la
calotte
pendant son sommeil je vais lui refaire
la moustache
on verra bientôt testera le champion
quand tu fais un balai c'est 200
champignons qui j'écris
m